hello everybody welcome to the NCBI
webinar today
this is Peter Cooper this is a short
webinar we may not have time to address
questions at the end but if you think of
any questions please type them in the
questions pod we will answer them in a
document that we'll post on our webinars
in courses page but after the webinar
and there's a link a compressed URL link
to the directory on our ftp site that
has these slides as well as the other
materials that i'm going to be talking
about today some of the command lines
i'm going to be showing you also the
recording will be in there once we
process it as well so today we're going
to talking talk about downloading genome
data in particular I'm talking about
sequences and the corresponding
annotation files from the NCBI FTP site
and my email address is there on this
slide so if you have any questions about
the contents of this webinar feel free
to write to me we'll talk more about
contacting us again at the end of the
webinar so today I'm just going to talk
about these topics quickly with some
slides then we'll go over to the command
line and show you some will use both the
web pages in the command line to
download some genome sequences so we'll
talk about assembly which is our main
web presence in our main way of
organizing the genome sequence data I'll
talk about the what I'm going to call
the new genomes FTP site but the new
organization has been there for a couple
of years but a lot of people still don't
know about this and then we'll go over
some recommendations for downloading
assemblies show you how to do that and
I'll mention the genomes announced email
list has been restarted recently there
will be a good way for you to find out
about things that are changing about our
genome site and like I said we'll do
some quick demos with some of the tools
for downloading things so just a
terminology thing today what I'm talking
about genome sequences I'm gonna be
calling them assemblies and those are
the things that we're going to be
downloading those are the sequences that
are sort of models of a genome the
genome itself is sort of an abstract
concept in a way it's an idealized
concept that's the thing that exists in
an individual person or organism but
we're going to be downloading today our
assemblies of genomes or representations
of genomes that's why the resource we're
going to be using is called assembly
this is what the web resource looks like
this is what our entre databases we call
them and it's the way basically of
finding out about what sequences are
available genome sequences for
particular organisms and even
metagenomes are in here now so it tells
you about the assembly structure where
you now have accession numbers for
assemblies GCA for GenBank assemblies
and GCF for our refseq assemblies this
is the way you're gonna be able to track
the relationship between genbank and
refseq and it's the basis for the
organization of the ftp site which we're
gonna be talking about extensively
notice that I've circled on this page
here this picture of the page really the
link to the genomes genome downloads FAQ
a lot of what I'm going to be telling
you today is based on that FAQ and it's
worth a read I didn't write it Paul kids
wrote it but it's very useful and really
gets you started on how to do these
kinds of things at NCBI so if we look at
a page this is the one for the human
assembly the sibling name here is grch38
patch eight you can download either the
refseq version or the submitted GenBank
version a assembly by following these
links here I'm not going to go over the
contents of the assembly pages in this
webinar because we're going to be mainly
talking about the FTP site and how to
get the data out of there so if you go
to our FTP site and the base URL here is
the FTP NCBI dot NL m dot H that gov and
I'll show you that in just a minute
again there are two there are three main
directories there there's a genomes all
directory and that's we're going to be
pointing a lot of our URL paths today
you can't browse this currently if you
tried to open this up in your web
browser your web browser would fall over
because there are more than 45,000
directories in there I'll talk in a
minute about the fact that we're going
to restructure that soon to make it
easier to deal with of course if you're
targeting specific files and directories
in here and you have the past then
there's no problem to do this but you
don't want to open it in your web
browser or browse it in any way the two
directories that are browsable or the
genomes GenBank and the genomes or
refseq directory they support browsing
and they support downloading for high
level taxonomic groups or you can drill
your way down to the species level if
you want to and we'll do a little bit of
that today
if you go into the FTP
directory's here the genomes GenBank
directories on the Left genomes refseq
directories on the right you can see the
organization by taxonomic group groups
of organisms really not necessarily
taxonomic groups within those there are
these assemblies assembly summary text
files and these are the files where you
would go to get the paths to download
data and well you can certainly see
examples of that on that genome though
in fact today I'm going to show you how
to get them using edirect which does
basically the same thing in fact from
the assembly summary file what you'll
find in there the most useful thing
really one of the most useful things is
this column 20 in that tab delimited
file which is your FTP path and we can
also get that as I said using a direct
if you look at the directories for
particular assemblies you'll see them
like this on the left is a prokaryotic
assembly that's for the staph aureus
reference genome and the one on the
right is for the human reference genome
you can see there are lots of different
kinds of files in there there are
sequence files there are annotation
files which include things like the gf3
file I'm not going to go over what all
these files are today that's really not
the point of this particular discussion
but the file descriptions are included
in that FTP FAQ that I pointed you to a
few minutes ago take a look at that
there's also a readme on the FTP site
that describes what's the contents of
these files are like I also wanted to
mention to you that I mentioned this in
passing a minute ago we're going to be
very soon changing the way the structure
of the genome as a whole directory looks
now in principle the things that I'm
showing you today will not be affected
by this change at all because basically
what you're going to be doing is getting
the paths to these directories and they
will just simply change but you'll still
be getting the path so it doesn't really
matter just to show you what's going to
happen is we're gonna make these sort of
hierarchical directories now so you can
browse them and so the directory
structure is going to be based on the
assembly accession number and so every
three digits will represent another
level and that directory tree to make it
possible to browse it but as I said it's
not going to affect the workflows that
we're going to be talking about
you can still browse the genomes GenBank
directory or the genomes refseq
directory and you can use as assembly
summary text files any direct as I'll
show you today to get the new URLs
notice that the directories are named by
the accession got version of the
assembly and the assembly name and that
won't change either so how are you gonna
get data out of this FTP site for a few
assemblies a small number you can use on
tray and we'll do that in a minute to
find an access the right director in the
FTP site for batches you can use a
director or assembly the assembly
summary text files to get passed into
directories and the files you want you
can even download directories from the
GenBank genomes or the I mean genomes
GenBank or genomes refseq directories on
the FTP site and I'll show you how to do
that so I'm going to be showing you a
couple of command-line programs which
are pretty good ways of doing this on a
UNIX system and you can use them you get
on Windows as well one way to get things
down is to use the NCBI or sync server
which is probably one of the fastest
ways of doing this I'll demonstrate that
today you could also use W get with
these FTP paths or curl if you want to
do download the files or directory if
you have to download a large number of
files you can even write a simple script
that calls our sink or W you get to do
this there is a sample Perl script
that's in the materials directory for
this particular talk and you can see
that if you go to that directory on the
FTP slate and the code for that Perl
script is included on the file I'm going
to show you in just a minute so let's go
ahead and go to the command line and
we'll do a few things before we have to
wrap this up so we're work with getting
fungal assemblies will show you how to
use our sink to download data and I'll
show you how use W get to download
directories and files so I'm going to go
out of this and I'm going to pull up a
command prompt so you should be seeing a
command prompt here I'm one of the
server's at NCBI and what I'm going to
do is on
FTP site there's a list of commands that
we're going to be going through is
basically the demo here and one of the
first things I want to do is just to use
the assembly resource to get a
particular path to a genome this is an
entre query you could write this
yourself or you could get it by using
the filter options on the assembly
resource so I'm going to go on to
another tab over here go to the NCBI
home page go to assembly so I have some
filters on I'm going to turn them off
this is the assembly home page and this
by the way at the bottom there is that
link to that add a cue which will be
very important if you want to try to do
these kinds of things I'm going to go
ahead and paste this Andre query end and
so I've got six of the complete fungal
genomes here you can see them here what
I want to do is quickly get you to the
path to download one of these genomes
this is the one we're going to download
this is the sacrum icy service II the
east reference genome in fact if I click
here that takes me to the assembly
record there are lots of things here
that we don't have really time to talk
about today notice we can see that
assembly accession number here for the
refseq it also references the GenBank
assembly here we can go straight into
the refseq assembly page here to
download this this is going to take us
to the FTP site and you can see the URL
here which is the one that goes into
genomes all but goes to a specific
directory for the assembly accession and
then the underscore character and the
name of the assembly so with an FTP
client or even with the web browser you
can download files individually if you
want to but let me quickly show you that
you can do this very easily using rsync
and i'm going to show you some command
lines here in the next couple of minutes
I'm not going to explain everything
that's on them if you want to know what
all those options are you can look at
the man pages for the different programs
man page for our sink and the man page
for W get when we get there to that one
so let's just do an our sink command to
download all of this data that's in here
that's going to be the sequence files
the annotation files plus the disk
directory here which contains more files
which are chromosome by chromosome and
information about how the assembly was
put together so I'm going to go back to
my script here and this is the our sink
command we're going to do to get that
down
pull the trigger pretty fast on that one
so let me go back up here because I
wanted to just mention a couple things
so this is the basic command and these
things have to do with whether we're
gonna keep turn symbolic links into
files and things like that
recursive means we're going to continue
down the directory tree structure to get
things and this is essentially the URL
for the FTP site replaced the protocols
replaced with our sink here and that's
what you do to get these and that I just
told it to put this in a directory
called
East and then it tells me the
information from the server and it
downloaded all of that stuff including
the directory structure to my hard drive
here and there's the East directory
there and there all the files that were
at present on the FTP site so while
we're here let me just show you
something else another kind of download
that we might want to do so we're in
genomes all but what if we wanted to get
the fall of the fungi reference
sequences so what I can do is change
these genomes all directory here I'm
going to do this by hand so now I'm
looking here at this directory here
which is contains all the different
organism groups here so I could download
for example suppose I wanted to download
all the complete fungal genomes here or
all of them in fact if I wanted to so I
could write a narcing command that do
that really easily this is the one I
want to use and I'll discuss this one a
little bit so what this one's going to
do is it's going to go through here and
avoid a lot of the directories that are
in there and basically it's going to get
rid of the assembly structured directory
it's going to get rid of the latest
assembly versions and it's going to get
me the protein fast a file from each one
of these
so this is a rather long complex or sink
command line but you can look at all
these options yourself and see what they
do
so let's try to run this one this is a
rather complicated one what it's going
to do for us is it's going to give us
all of the protein files so this one
will take about 15 seconds to Ramat see
what happens
so notices what's happening it's
reproducing the directory structured
tree that's present at NCBI so this is
basically mirroring the data but it's
getting a specific file from each one of
these directories so we're just going to
get the protein files from each one of
these fungal genomes so we can see
they're all there if we wanted to we
could go into the Saccharomyces
directory so we have the reference
genome that directory is retained from
the NCBI side also this one which is the
assembly accession and you could do some
things to make sure that to make it so
you didn't get all of these directories
if you didn't want them and there's a
protein file so those are it's a fast a
file of all the proteins that are
annotated on that particular genome ok
now there's some other examples in here
using our sink and you can take a look
at them I want to move on to the next
way of doing things which is to try to
use double you get you could also use
arcing to do the kinds of things I'm
going to do next this is a basically the
strategy of trying to get the FTP paths
either from the assembly summary dot txt
file or to get them from eat erect so
I'm going to use a direct to do that and
we have a webinar any direct if you need
more information about edirect but i'm
going to use that to get the paths
so this is my e direct command basically
it's going to use the same query that we
used in the assembly resource then I'm
going to use a fetch to get the document
summary and within the document summary
there is a section that has the FTP file
pass in it so I basically can get out
the refseq FTP directories out of that
so let's try that and see how that works
so the only thing that's I've added to
this is there's a little said command at
the end that will add that front slash
the directory symbol at the end of these
to make them directories which will make
them work a little bit better with W yet
and so that file contains URLs that
would take me directly to those
directories and I could potentially
download those exactly the same way I
did before I could use a different way
to do that if I want to and the way that
I was going to show you was to use W get
so what this will do is get me the same
kind of information that I got for the
yeast but for all of those complete
genomes this is a taller order maybe not
than the one we did a minute ago and the
different options here hard ways of
dealing with the kinds of default
directories that W get will put on your
machine you can organize those in
different ways by choosing how many
directories to cut and so on and so
forth again I refer you to the W get man
page for this information and I'm going
to put it into a directory called
complete fungal
so I now have directories for all of the
different complete the six complete
fungal genomes that we saw a minute ago
using the assembly resource and so for
example I went into the yeast directory
here and what I did one of the switches
that I added to that when I think I see
here so I didn't get the semi redundant
the assembly structure directory was not
in that command line so I didn't get
that if I wanted to I could have done
that by changing the level I have a
level one here which means I won't
descend but I could have descended into
the next level to got to get these the
last example which I won't do today goes
ahead and gets a particular file out of
each one of these directories and you
can do that with double you get you can
also do that with the Perl script that's
included in the directory for the
materials of this particular plot that
are on the FTP side and so all that
stuff including those additional
examples are in that text file that's on
the FTP site so before I conclude let me
just go ahead and throw up another slide
which has some information about staying
current and also just to remind you of
something I said earlier the the mailman
list or the email list for genomes
announced has been revived it was kind
of dead for a while but it's now going
to provide you with information about
changes to the genomes area of the ftp
site for example the kind of change i
was talking about with the genomes all
directory the genome download FAQ
document is there again when I have
these sort of abbreviations those are
the abbreviations like NCBI and angle
brackets that just means the NCBI home
page URL goes there
likewise when it's an FTP and angle
brackets that just means the URL for the
NCBI FTP site goes there I also wanted
to remind you that we have an ncbi help
manual that's listed there and that has
good instructions on how to use eject
there are a bunch of very useful fact
sheets and there's one specific to
downloading this genomic data which
gives you the same kind of information
we talked about today right to the help
desk with any general questions
or you can write to me and my email
address is was given to you at the
beginning it's pretty easy it's just my
name Peter Cooper at NIH suck up if you
have questions about the webinars the
structure of them or you know when are
we going to do a webinar on this that or
the other one of the file is going to be
ready those kinds of things and that the
webinars so I'll go ahead and conclude
there and I think we can hang around for
about five minutes or so if there's any
questions that are general okay so there
there don't seem to be any if you have
questions you can write them in the
questions pod
we'll make a document that has any
questions that came in during the talk
that Wayne answered and put that up on
the FTP site okay so I guess we're go
ahead and wrap it up thank you all for
coming and we'll talk to you next time
you